come on jeff come on up here come on up
here
style has arrived can we just get a shot
go get a shot of this
those are satin pants aren't they uh
silk they're i call them i call them a
technical silk technical and this too
technical
listen i just learned something that's
what you do you educate the world no no
can you fly have you flashed back to the
first
one of these the first premiere do you
think about that and think about this
i haven't until this second i like what
you've triggered just a second i'm
having a regression
therapy
yes
what do you remember about that first
one well the premiere there you know
there were a few with things like this
you know we already did a kind of a
premiere in mexico city which was great
which was great this is fantastic my
home
base not far from my
stomping grounds you know so to speak
speaking of dinosaurs and uh it's it's
great let me see i think where did we
have the first one well i'll tell you
you know the first one we had i'm
remembering london i'm remembering the
the um
natural museum history of a natural
museum history there
national history museum and and we
showed it to speaking of the jubilee the
platinum jubilee we showed it to at the
time princess diana and we had a kind of
a royal screening
you know sam neil was here
princess diana was here you know and we
showed and we showed them the movie that
was standing there next to diana
outstanding setting
watch a movie with popcorn popcorn yes
how about that sheared popcorn with her
that's all i can say no
she was i was
very much a gentleman she was
a spectacular lady
special um
you look at this tonight and what does
it mean though
the last go round
perhaps for you yeah yeah well you know
none of us ever know when it might be
the last go-around
that sandbag may take us both out right
now oh and then he then it did can you
imagine those were his last words um so
um but
yes
30 years geez i never did anything that
lasted 30 years like that it's kind of
an amazing you know trippy little
experience and now i'm just processing
it now because here we are at this
moment we've waited a long time to offer
it at your
worthy feet
and i got to look at those feet and
i realized even more worthy than i don't
know if i'm worthy